[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halallweg guten Abend an diesem
Reformationstag Norbert Lehmann ist auch
dabei für den Sport einen schönen guten
Abend auch von mir und das sind die
Nachrichtenthemen von
heute Grundsatzurteil aus Karlsruhe wer
freigesprochen wurde darf nicht noch mal
wegen derselben Tat angeklagt werden
auch nicht bei
Mord Vorstoß mit Bodentruppen Israels
Armee dringt immer tiefer in den
Gazastreifen vor und weitet den Kampf
gegen die Hamas
aus und wieder eine Fußball WM in der
Wüste weil Australien auf eine Bewerbung
verzichtet ist der Weg frei für
Saudi-Arabien als Gastgeber
2034 wir beginnen mit dem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts das viele
aufwühlen dürfte und von dem selbst die
Richter sagen es sei schmerzhaft für die
Angehörigen danach ist es
verfassungswidrig jemanden zweimal für
dieselbe Straftat anzuklagen selbst dann
wenn es um Mord geht und neue Beweise
auftauchen geklagt hatte ein
mutmaßlicher Mörder Sarah Tacke mit
Details sie wurde vergewaltigt und
erstochen
1981 Frederike von Müllmann damals 17
Jahre Schülerin er ISM h der Tat chtige
wird aus Mangel an Beweisen
freigesprochen doch 31 Jahre später
zeigt eine moderne dnaanalyse dass er
doch der Mörder sein könnte Spermaspuren
belasten ihn durch das Urteil der
Verfassungsrichterin und Richter heute
ist allerdings klar ISM h darf für den
Mord an Frederike Müllmann nicht wieder
angeklagt werden dem Senat ist bewusst
dass dieses Ergebnis für die Angehörigen
der
1981 getöteten Schülerin schmerzhaft und
gewiss nicht leicht zu akzeptieren ist
der Grund für die Entscheidung des
Gerichts liegt hier im Grundgesetz den
Artikel 103 Absatz 3 schreibt vor
niemand darf wegen derselben Tat
mehrmals bestraft
werden bei dieser Bestimmung handelt es
sich nicht um ein bloßes mehrfach
bestrafungs sondern um ein mehrfach
verfolgungsverbot dieses schützt nicht
nur bereits einmal verurteilte sondern
auch freigesprochene Personen vor einem
erneuten Strafverfahren heißt konkret
durch das Urteil heute kann sich ein
einmal freigesprochener wie ISM trotz
neuer belastender Beweise auf diesen
Freispruch verlassen damit siegt heute
Rechtssicherheit über
Gerechtigkeit wir wollen es noch
vertiefen mit Sarah Tacke unserer
Rechtsexpertin SAR mutmaßliche Mörder
sollten zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden
sollte man meinen egal wann warum hat
das Gericht anders entschieden die
Richter und Richter haben heute mit
ihrem Urteil ganz klar gemacht dass
Rechtsicherheit also die Sicherheit
eines einmal rechtskräftig
Freigesprochenen auch eines einmal
rechtskräftig Freigesprochenen Mörders
schwerer wiegt als Gerechtigkeit also
dass ein Täter auch zur Rechenschaft
gezogen wird und die Argument liegt im
Grundgesetz Artikel 103 Absatz 3
Grundgesetz das sogenannte
doppelbestrafungsverbot weil die Richter
heute in ihrer Entscheidung gesagt haben
und damit auch festgelegt haben dass
dieser Grundsatz absolut gilt heißt
konkret dass jemand der einmal
freigesprochen wurde auch ein Mörder
selbst wenn sich im Nachhinein
herausstellt dass er
höchstwahrscheinlich der Täter war nicht
wieder angeklagt werden darf und sie
haben auch noch mal gesagt
Doppelbestrafung ist nicht wörtlich zu
nehmen heißt nicht nur dass jemand nicht
doppelt bestraft werden darf sondern
umfasst auch dass jemand und dass es
verboten ist jemanden doppelt anzuklagen
mm welche Folgen hat diese Entscheidung
für alle Mörder heißt das wenn sie
einmal rechtskräftig freigesprochen sind
haben sie Rechtssicherheit können auf
diesen Freispruch Vertrauen und für uns
als Gesellschaft heißt das dass wir auch
mit Urteilen leben müssen selbst wenn
sich im Nachhinein als falsch erweisen
das heißt Rechtssicherheit
übergerechtigkeit eine Entscheidung die
dem Rechtsempfinden vieler widersprechen
dürfte ganz herzlichen Dank für diese
Einschätzung Sarah
Tacke jetzt nach Israel
Ministerpräsident Netanyahu lehnt eine
Waffenruhe trotz der internationalen
Aufrufe ab das wäre eine Kapitulation
gegenüber dem Hamas Terror auch die USA
argumentieren eine generelle Waffenruhe
würde der Hamas in die Hände spielen und
so bombardieren sich beide Seiten
gegenseitig weiter die Hamas meldete vor
einer Stunde den Beschuss eines
Flüchtlingslagers in Gaza mit vielen
Toten Tim
Krüger die Zerstörung ist kaum greifbar
ein gigantischer Krater mitten im
Flüchtlingscamp im Norden des
Gazastreifens Menschen suchen mit blosen
Händen nach Verschütteten die
radikalislam Hamas macht einen
israelischen Angriff dafür
verantwortlich mindestens 50 Menschen
sein ums Leben gekommen die israelischen
Streitkräfte sagen es sein
hamasterroristen getötet worden eine
große Anzahl an Verletzten ist zu uns
gekommen als eine starke expplosion das
Flüchtlingslager erschüttert hat auch am
Boden intensivieren sich die Kämpfe
diese Bilder sollen in der Nähe der
Ortschaft beanun entstanden sein die
Hamas hat sie heute veröffentlicht
offenbar sind Hamas Kämpfer zu sehen die
sich mit israelischen Truppen Gefechte
liefern auch das israelische Militär hat
Bilder veröffentlicht die zu bestätigen
scheinen dass die eigenen Soldaten immer
tiefer in den gaserstreifen vordringen
unsere Soldaten kämpfen derzeit mit Mut
und Tapferkeit auf dem Schlachtfeld es
gibt erbitterte Kämpfe in denen
Terroristen getötet werden es wird von
Angesicht zu Angesicht
gekämpft ein Hoffnungsschimmer in diesem
Krieg mit unbändiger Freude feierten
Angehörige und Verwandte die Befreiung
der israelischen Soldaten
edisch aus den Händen der
Hamas und wie jeden Tag gab es auch
wieder in Israel Luftalarm dieses Mal
wurde die Stadt erstott von einer Rakete
aus Gaza
getroffen ein wenig im Schatten der
Ereignisse in Gaza ist die Lage im
Westjordanland nach den Terrorattacken
der hamass am 7 oktober hat auch hier
die Gewalt zugenommen besonders rund um
die von Elis errichteten Siedlungen es
kommt zu Zusammenstößen oft auch zu
Übergriffen extremistischer Siedler
dabei wurden nach Angaben des
palästinensischen
Gesundheitsministeriums 122 Menschen
getötet ein Schauplatz der kleine Ort
assavia Alisa jung war
da die Olivenernte im Westjordanland hat
begonnen viele Palästinenser Leben davon
ganz in der Nähe der Heine jüdische
Siedlungen ein Siedler hat Ihnen am
Montag 12 Säcke die gesamte tagesernte
abgenommen erzählt uns hammad
alweisi er hatte eine Waffe wir haben
keine wenn er eine hat und auf dich
zielt wie soll ich dann meine Oliven
zurückverlangen fährt man durch die
Westbank sieht man ein Land durchzogen
von Zäunen die die Siedlungen schützen
sollen immer wieder kommt es zu Gewalt
auf beiden Seiten jüdische Siedler gegen
Palästinenser Palästinenser gegen
jüdische Siedler
seit dem 7 oktober trifft die Gewalt vor
allem Palästinenser die Regierung hat in
den letzten di Wochen Waffen an die
jüdischen Siedler
verteilt der Palästinenser Bilal sal
starb vor drei Tagen hier rechts im Bild
kurz zuvor bei der Ernte mit seinen
Kindern drei Siedler hätten erst einmal
in die
Luft und dann in seine Brust geschossen
erzählt uns sein
Schwager er hat sich nach seinem Telefon
gebückt und sie haben zweimal direkt auf
ihn gefeuert ein Sprecher der Siedler
sagt sie hätten auf die Beine geziäht
sie wurden attackiert von Hamas
Angreifern mit großen und kleinen
Steinen Bilal und seine Familie
pflückten Oliven er war sofort tot es
gibt keine Hoffnung wir haben einen
Punkt erreicht wo es keine Hoffnung mehr
gibt Bilal hinterlässt seine Frau und
vier
Kinder mehr zur Situation im
Westjordanland und in Gaza gibt es ab 19
Uhr
bei ZDF heute live auf unseren Social
Media Kanälen und in der ZDF heute App
zu
sehen als die Taliban in Afghanistan die
Macht übernahmen flohen hunderttausende
ins Nachbarland Pakistan insgesamt
halten sich nach Schätzung der Vereinten
Nationen mehr als 2 Millionen Afghanen
illegal dort auf jetzt verlassen
Tausende das Land in Lastwagen und nur
mit dem Beladen was sie tragen können
die pakistanische Regierung hat ihnen
bis morgen Zeit gegeben auszureisen
droht mit Festnahmen und
zwangsabschiebungen
menschenrechtsorganisationen kritisieren
das Vorgehen und warnen vor einer
humanitären
Notlage die Fußball WM
2034 wird so wie es aussieht in
Saudi-Arabien stattfinden heute endete
die Bewerbungsfrist und nach der Absage
Australiens ist das Königreich als
einziger Kandidat übrig geblieben das
macht nicht nur
Menschenrechtsorganisationen fassungslos
denn Saudi-Arabien ist noch umstrittener
als der letztjährige Ausrichter Qatar
pumpt aber auch Milliarden in den Sport
Julia Schröter und Marcel Bergmann
berichten Saudi-Arabien als Gastgeber
der WM
2034 viele glauben dass Johnny Infantino
dafür die Strippen gezogen hat der
umstrittene FIFA Boss hat enge
Verbindungen in den Golfstaat erst
letzte Woche noch traf er mit dem
saudischen Kronprinzen zusammen
der Hintergrund des ganzen Anfang
Oktober hatte die FIFA entschieden dass
die WM 2030 in Ländern auf drei
Kontinenten ausgetragen wird nach dem
Rotationsprinzip kommen damit für die WM
2034 nur Ausrichter aus Asien und
Ozeanien in Frage mit dem Rückzug des
letzten Mitbewerbers Australien bleibt
jetzt nur noch Saudi-Arabien
übrig Menschenrechtler sehen das als
Skandal und benennen Beispiele für die
katastrophale im Land
Massenhinrichtungen Folter von
Oppositionellen Unterdrückung von Frauen
das Signal wird gesendet dass es der
FIFA schnurzpiep egal ist wenn es um
Menschenrechte geht und dass die FIFA
auch pfeift auf ihre internationalen
Verpflichtungen die sie nach den
Richtlinien der Vereinten Nationen
eigentlich hat Saudi-Arabien drängt mit
viel Geld auf die Fußballbühne
verpflichtet Superstars wie Cristiano
Ronaldo Neymar und Karim Benzema das
Ziel weg vom Öl hin zu mehr Bedeutung
auf anderen Ebenen wie eben dem Sport
und da scheint das Land nun einen großen
Schritt weiter gekommen zu
sein nach Bayern nach seiner Wiederwahl
hat CSU Ministerpräsident Söder im
Landtag für Geschlossenheit und Fairness
unter den Demokraten geworben wir
bewegen uns in ernsten Zeiten sagte
Söder der CSU Chef erhielt in der
geheimen Abstimmung 120 der 198
abgegebenen Stimmen Söder regiert seit
2018 mit den Freien Wählern mit dabei in
der Plenarsitzung war auch der AFD
Politiker Daniel halemba der gestern
vorübergehend festgenommen worden war
gegen den 22-Jährigen wird unter anderem
wegen des Verdachts der Volksverhetzung
ermittelt pünktlich zum Reformationstag
heute ist in der Marktkirche von
Hannover ein neues Kirchenfenster
eingeweiht worden wobei pünktlich
relativ ist ist dauerte Jahre bis man
sich dort einig wurde denn das
lutherfenster des Künstlers Markus
lüppertz ist tatsächlich speziell zudem
gefordert von Gerhard Schröder dem
Exkanzler was vielen auch nicht gefiel
Svenja
domeierer Martin Luther als
kirchenglaskunst mit erschrockenem Blick
den Tod im Nacken der glaubensreformer
als getriebener mit einem Festakt wurde
das auffällige und umstrittene Kunstwerk
heute eingeweiht wir freuen uns dass
nach 7 Jahren auch Ringen und m
Herausforderung wir heute in der Lage
sind das Fenster der Öffentlichkeit zu
präsentieren erst hatte der Erbe des
nachkriegsarchitekten den Einbau des
Fensters mit einem Rechtsstreit
blockiert dann folgte Knatsch mit dem
Altbundeskanzler Gerhard Schröder hatte
das Projekt initiiert und Spenden
gesammelt als er sich nach dem
russischen Angriffskrieg nicht von Putin
distanzieren will leitet die Kirche den
Großteil des Geldes an einen
ukraineefond um heute stehen die Zeichen
auf Versöhnung das Ergebnis zählt das
Fenster ist eingebaut und viele Menschen
werden sich darüber freuen und für eine
lange Zeit die Kirchengemeinde selbst
hat das Fenster vorfinanziert und bemüht
sich nun nachträglich um Geldgeber Gram
sei man sich nicht mehr auch wenn das
Werk des Künstlers lange auf Publikum
warten musste ich war
beleidigt was soll ich sonst sag weil
ich da einfach diese ganzen quirelen die
es gab sind einfach lächerlich ich kann
nur sagen ich komme hier rein sehe das
Fenster und find es großartig nicht
insofern unabig davon dass ich es
gemacht habe ein Kirchenfenster dessen
eigenwillige Geschichte schon jetzt
Menschen auseinander und wieder
zusammengebracht
hat mit ihm geht ein Stück
Fernsehgeschichte Elmar Wepper ist
gestorben im Alter von 79 Jahren er habe
keine große Angst vor dem Tod sagte er
mal nur vor der Art des Sterbens vor
siegtum oder Demenz das ist ihm erspart
geblieben er starb nach Medienberichten
heute morgen überraschend an
Herzversagen Christoph desterell
erinnert
ah das ist also jawohl her Kommissar
guten tagr Kommissar der Kommissar die
Krimiserie der Zeit es ist 1974
Emma Wepper erbt vom großen Bruder Fritz
seine erste große Rolle wird neu
Assistent und folgt ihm so ins
Rampenlicht für mehr als vier
Jahrzehnte gemacht haben noch im Krieg
geboren sieht er früh wie sich der zwei
Jahre ältere Fritz fürs Theater
begeistert und zieht mit beide landen
beim Film beiden hört und fühlt man das
bayerische an entsprechende Rollen
kommen rein Serie über Serie Elma Wepper
laufend in den deutschen Wohnzimmern
leicht nicht seicht am liebsten mit
uschiglas so kennen und mögen ihn die
Leute zwei Münchner in Hamburg perfekte
Chemie habe heute morgen was vergessen
was vergessen
ja er ist über 60 als völlig unverhofft
Karriere 2 beginnt die Lola für die
beste männliche Hauptrolle geht an Elma
Wepper als Charakter dararsteller 2008
gewinnt er den Deutschen Filmpreis für
Kirschblüten Hanami einen schwer
krebskranken Mann spieltte in dieser
Geschichte übers Leben lieben sterben
und verstehen was all das
[Musik]
bedeutet das ist für dich es ist etwas
was ich in der Form nie gemacht habe und
was was ganz Besonderes ist mit
eigentlich mit keiner Rolle die ich bis
jetzt gemacht habe obwohl viele schöne
dabei waren vergleichbar melancholisch
bis Grantler sehr viele schöne Rollen
kam da im Ganzen zusammen ein paar davon
nicht nur im Kommissar Bruder hererz mit
dem Bruder als
Bruder Umarmung schön in einer knappen
Stunde geht's hier im ZDF los sber DFB
Pokal zweite Runde mit den großen
traditionsf Kaisers Lautern gegen Köln
die Roten Teufel gegen die geistböcke
Lautern in Liga 2 Bisang richtig stark
der FC in Liga 1 dagegen schwach 50.000
Zuschauer sind im ausverkauften Stadion
Katrin müllerhohnstein in Kaiserslautern
der Betzenberg bebt ja der Betzenberg
wird beben der Betzenberg wird leben und
so sieht dieses Stadion aus wenn man aus
der Stadt hinaufchaut das fritzwalter
Stadion tront oben auf auf dem Berg war
schon so oft in dieser Saison
ausverkauft die Mannschaft begeistert
ihre Fans mit vielen Toren wer noch
einen fanschall braucht der besorgt den
ganz schnell denn es kommen die Kölner
die in der Liga aktuell große Probleme
haben gerade erst gegen Leipzig mit 0 Z6
unter die Räder gekommen aber es ist ein
Duell der Traditionsvereine beide mit
einer langen Historie Tradition schießt
natürlich keine Tore gewinnt auch keine
Spiele sorgt aber für große Emotionen
und darauf freuen wir uns heute Abend im
Pokalfight zwischen Kaiserslautern und
Köln ab 20:15 Uhr sind wir live drauf
danke Katrin bis gleich dann ja und wer
lieber das nations League Spiel der DFB
Frauen sehen will das gibt's bei uns im
Livestream ab 19:55 Uhr Island gegen
Deutschland zu sehen bei ZDF heute und
in der ZDF heute
App Tennis Olympiasieger Alexander SF
ist beim ATP mastersier in Paris eine
Runde weiter allerdings hatte der
Hamburger große Mühe gegen den jungen
ungarischen Qualifikanten Maron futobic
gewann aber dann am Ende doch knapp mit
46 7 Z5 und 6
Z4 Fußballweltmeister Lionel Messi und
Weltmeisterin aitana bon mati sind die
Gewinner des Ballon dor der Argentinier
erhelt die prestigeträchtige
Auszeichnung zum achten Mal und widmete
sie seinem verstorbenen nzmo
maradonnaana bon hatte mit Spanien den
wmtitel und mit Barcelona die Champions
League
gewonnen gratulieren wir doch herzlich
ja klar und wenn jemand heute Abend bei
ihnen klingelt und lautstark Süßes oder
Saures fordert nicht erschrecken sie
wissen ja heute ist Halloween weltweit
gefeiert von vielen großen und kleinen
Menschen wie hier bereits gestern in
Washington der Mann mit der
Baseballkappe ist übrigens Präsident
Biden er verteilte vor dem Weißen Haus
Süßigkeiten und Bücher ausgewanderte
Iren haben dieses Brauchtum in den
Vereinigten Staaten populär gemacht und
längst auch bei uns der november beginnt
wie der oktober endet unbeständig die
Details hat gleich Christa Orben das
heute journal mit Christian siers in der
Halbzeitpause um 21:30 Uhr und hier
übernimmt morgen Jana pareiges wir
wünschen Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend
auf bald und auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend der Oktober geht jetzt zu
Ende aber die Serie atlantischer
regentiefs noch lange nicht wir sollten
allerdings besonders dieses Tief hier im
Auge behalten das entwickelt sich jetzt
nämlich wahnsinnig schnell bringt
Orkanböhen und Meter hohe Wellen nach
Nordwesteuropa uns beschäftigt es
allerdings erst am Donnerstag und dann
auch in de ich abgeschwächter Form wir
haben es jetzt erstmal mit der warm und
der Kaltfront dieses zweiten Tiefs zu
tun und an der warmfont gibt's heute
Nacht wieder viele Wolken und etwas
Regen wenn es im Süden aufklart gibt's
hier Nebel im Norden können dann in
schleswg- Holstein sogar vereinzelt
frostwerte möglich sein genauso wie in
den Alpentälern im Süden ansonsten
sinken die Temperaturen auf 10 bis 4°
morgen erreichen wir 9° auf Rügen und
17° am oberrehein dazu startet der
november im Süden und auch im Osten mit
relativ viel Sonne von der Nordsee bis
zum erdsgebge gibt's allerdings diese
Wolken mit etwas Regen die sich
nachmittags dann ganz in den Norden
zurückziehen dann kommen von Westen dann
aber schon die Regenwolken der nächsten
Front das ganze bei einem lebhaften
südlichen Wind im Berglagen mit
stürmischen böhnen Sturmböen bisschen
die Tieflagen erreichen wir am
Donnerstag im Westen des Landes am
Freitag sinkt die Schneefallgrenze auf
1000 m in den Alpen und am Samstag kommt
schon das nächste Sturmtief also es ist
viel los beim Wetter
tschüss